da kann man gar nicht neutral zu hören
da ist man sofort mir geht es jedenfalls
so ergriffen und ich merke auch wie in
mir ein gedanke aufkommt den man schon
vergessen hat also sind jetzt angewiesen
auf unsere bundeswehr soldaten wir sind
angewiesen auf unsere elitetruppen wir
sind angewiesen auf die männer die noch
vor ein zwei jahren von der politischen
linken in deutschland als eine bande von
neonazis und rechtsextreme ungefähr dann
bezeichnet worden ist wir waren ja so
weit dass die einheit die ksk der jetzt
eine wichtige rolle zukommt aufgelöst
werden sollte wegen rechtsradikaler
umtriebe und all dem da war sie da half
es gab ja in der test gar doch es gab
für vorfälle die sind aber aber die
haltung insbesondere links von der mitte
das ist militär militär ist apriori
rechts und eigentlich böse das wollen
nur nicht aber jetzt in der situation in
der wir uns befinden brauchen sie und
jetzt werden die gleichen leute die sie
auflösen wollten sie zu helden erklären
für mich ist das heuchelei was meinst du
wie geht es wenn diese soldaten aus
diesem einsatz wiederkommen kümmert sich
dann jemand um diese soldaten weil es
ist ja auch dringend nötig wie ärgert
uns auch gerade bewiesen hat
offensichtlicher zu wenig wenn man es
vergleicht
wenn einer in auffahrunfall hat der und
hat ein kleines schleudertrauma was da
passiert die versicherung wenn du ein
psychologisches gutachten willst weil du
nicht mehr ins büro kannst und so und
was wir da tun was da der sozialstaat
unsere gesundheits unser
gesundheitswesen unser selbstverständnis
auffährt um ein opfer eines
auffahrunfalls den biss in den hals
wehtut zu versorgen und wenn ich dann
dagegen sehe wie allein wir die menschen
lassen die männer und frauen lassen wir
aus afghanistan zurückgekommen sind dann
belegt ist nur dass wir bis vor 14 tagen
diesen krieg ignoriert haben mit seinen
folgen das war aber auch da schon krieg
haben ein bisschen filmchen geguckt
tolle amerikanische filme wie das so ist
in den lagern angedacht europa oder gibt
es videospiele
das war wie so ein videospiel erlebnis
für die nation es war aber für unsere
soldaten bereits realität das war für
ihre frauen realität die angst hatten
das war für ihre kinder realität die
ihre väter verloren haben jetzt wird das
alles offenbar und jetzt ist die zeit
gekommen sich ehrlich zu machen
klaus wenn wir jetzt mal
ein szenario kreieren wollen ohne panik
zu machen
das ganze der ganze einsatz ging nach
den anschlägen am 11 september 2001 los
das war die reaktion darauf wenn wir
jetzt darüber nachdenken welche reaktion
es geben könnte dann ist das
wahrscheinlichste szenario das es zu
terroranschlägen kommen könnte einen
krieg können die taliban gegen die
amerikaner und die nato nicht gewinnen
wobei wir auch gesehen haben natürlich
kann auch die nato keinen krieg in
afghanistan gewinnen genauso wenig wie
die russen es vorher konnten oder dieser
wert wenn wir an anschlagsszenarien
denken was wäre das wahrscheinlichste
was passieren könnte na ja wir sind ein
paar wochen vorm elfter september und in
wahrheit spüren wir jetzt dass wir ganz
nah am 11 september sind natürlich
gehört zum kampf repertoire und zum
krieg signal einer terror-organisation
anschläge im westen zu machen sie müssen
den krieg übrigens auch gar nicht im
klassischen sinne gewinnen also dass man
irgendwie eine armee beschlägt oder so
was die zeiten sind wir vorbei sie
müssen uns dem westen und unseren
repräsentanten den politikern im westen
nur nachhaltig wehtun und das schafft
man mit einem anschlag in berlin das
schafft man mit einem anschlag in
amerika geschafft und mit einem anschlag
irgendwo in der westlichen welt und
lasst uns eines nicht unterschätzen auch
in kabul sind zehntausende von taliban
kämpfern die so hoch gerüstet sind wie
noch nie zuvor weil es hier all die
waffen der westlichen armeen haben die
wir da armee die afghanischen armee zur
verfügung gestellt haben die sind jetzt
in der hand der taliban wir haben es
jetzt mit der am besten am
hochgerüsteten terrororganisationen der
welt zu tun und wir hassen und das hat
auch mit den waffen umgehen können das
ganze problem land ja daran dass die
ganzen warnungen nicht wahrgenommen
wurden was auch daran liegt dass die
zuständigkeiten so groß verteilt sind
soweit rechtlich in
verteidigungsministerium im
außenministerium innenministerium
entwicklung wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit hat auch noch eine rolle
gespielt nun hatte armin laschet und
auch wolfgang ischinger der vorsitzende
der münchner sicherheitskonferenz hat
das unterstützt gefordert dass es einen
nationalen
sicherheitsrat geben müsse so wie es ihn
auch in den usa gibt es das eine gute
idee gut es kommt darauf an wer dann
mein vorschlag wäre dass wir erst mal
ein nationales sich ehrlich machen
anfangen bevor wir irgendwelche gremien
können wir können hier immer
irgendwelche gremien so ein
sicherheitsrat ist auch nichts anderes
als eine arbeitsgruppe wenn man nicht
mehr weiter weiß was man machen soll ich
bin ganz steigt dafür dass wir endlich
aufhören uns in die tasche zu lügen denn
meine wahrnehmung der letzten wochen ist
auch schon wieder das dass wir die
bürger von der politik für dumm verkauft
werden und ich will das gern begründen
wer also sagt wir müssen menschen aus
afghanistan raus holen der hat den
großen zuspruch der bevölkerung das
bedeutet aber auch wer a wie aus fliegen
sagt der muss auch b sagen wie blut zu
sagen wir können dort helfen ohne
menschenleben zu riskieren dass eine
wie soll ich es formulieren bürger
veräppelung erster ausmaß ist das zweite
ist wenn wir jetzt höre dass alle
politiker jetzt zu den größten frauen
freunden der weltgeschichte werden also
programm karrenbauer hat das gestern
hier erwähnt frauen müssten besonders
geschützt und aus afghanistan raus
geholt werden herr laschet hat das schon
thematisiert das ist im grunde der
kommune unserer unserer gesellschaft wir
hätten jetzt zuerst die frauen dann
würde ich aber sagen das sind doch auch
noch die ortskräfte und dann müssen wir
folgendes aussprechen wenn wir die
frauen und die ortskräfte retten wollen
dann retten wir halb oder dreiviertel
afghanistan weil die kommen ja nicht
allein sondern sie kommen mit ihren
familien sie kommen mit ihren freunden
sie kommen mit ihren schwerstbehinderten
bruder den man dann auch nicht
zurücklassen kann usw die sitzen ja zum
teil jetzt auch in ravenstein 6000
menschen was passiert mit also das und
das ist ehrlich gesagt mein dritter
punkt gut dass du darauf zu sprechen
kommt die dritte ehrlich machen muss
sein die amerikaner haben wir viele
menschen aus afghanistan evakuiert und
haben sie nach ramstein gebracht haben
steines bekanntlich in deutschland und
ich glaube zur ehrlich machen gehört
auch bevor man irgendwelche
sicherheitsräte er gründet sich klar zu
machen dass die amerikaner die natürlich
niemals alle 6000 nach amerika fliegen
werden sondern wir sind jetzt in
randstein und das sind sie und sie sind
in deutschland die sind also schon mal
da nochmal ich sage nicht dass wir
keinen menschen aufnehmen sollen ich
sage nur dass wir bitte die menschen in
deutschland von anfang an über die
konsequenzen
informieren und das bedeutet wer frauen
und ortskräfte sagt mein zehntausende um
nicht zu sagen 100.000 einverstanden
wenn man damit einverstanden ist ich
hätte da fragen gleichzeitig muss man
dazusagen der türkische präsident
erdogan hat schon angekündigt sein land
ist voll er hat die flüchtlinge
insbesondere aus syrien aber auch schon
aus afghanistan aufgenommen also ein
abkommen wie nach 2015 wo er uns
sozusagen die arbeit abnimmt wird es
nicht noch mal geben ja aber da möchte
man ja eigentlich aus dem folgten
brustton der überzeugung sagen unser
land ist auch voll wir haben 270.000
wenn ich das richtig im kopf hat
menschen aus afghanistan bereits eine
neue heimat gegeben wir haben jetzt
signalisiert dass wir ortskräfte nach
deutschland holen ich finde damit sind
wir unsere humanitären verpflichtungen
schon ein großes stück nachgekommen und
können jetzt nicht die türen und die
tore öffnen für jeden der kommen will
eine bemerkung noch so sicher wie das
amen in der kirche ich benutze bewusst
diese formulierung so sicher wie das
amen in der kirche eine formulierung aus
unserem kulturkreis so sicher wie das
amen in der kirche ist doch auch das mit
den strom der ortskräfte mit denen die
jetzt evakuiert werden auch wieder
straftäter und mutmaßliche terroristen
ins land einreisen und warum kann man
das nicht verhindern weil man erst in
deutschland checkt die identität und
vielleicht wird man genauso belogen wie
man 2015 belogen worden ist
[Musik]